we are digging into our own history here
at channel 8 our station was once owned
by the eccentric billionaire howard
hughes and there's a building in our
parking lot that we affectionately call
the hughes house where he actually
stayed back in the 1950s christian is
live out there in our backyard right now
to tell us more about it kristin
well denise this green bungalow believe
it or not was a was basically part of a
hotel we call it here at new zealand we
call it the hughes house and it's
sometimes it's called the greenhouse
esquel let me give you a quick tour here
inside now there's bathrooms here
there's also a kitchen and there's also
a dining room area basically with a huge
huge huge table now it stood in this
spot since the 50s hughes fell in love
with las vegas and leased it during that
decade at this time it was adjacent to
the desert inn hotel and stood on the
grounds of what was called the sun villa
motel and later the blair house motel
neither of those are here anymore of
course but this house is still standing
tall
the bungalow even made it to the big
screen appearing in the classic las
vegas mobster flick casino that tells
the story of the las vegas mobsters
lefty rosenthal and tony spelatro which
is played by robert de niro and joe
pesci in the movie it was used as the
home of the character portrayed by james
woods it is seen when sharon stone's
character runs off to la with him hughes
was a well-known movie lover and movie
maker himself inside there are classic
hughes items like old rotary phones and
some classic aviation photos of hues on
the wall now
back out here live with this live
picture hughes bought channel 8 in the
70s after he was staying at this
bungalow you can check out here some of
these pretty cool pieces now there is a
ton of interesting history in here and
associated with hue so over the next
month we want to share a little bit of
that history of course with all of our
viewers denise i'll send it back over to
you what christian didn't mention is
many people think that house is haunted